hello reject nation I'm Meg Alba yo I
know you're like a superstar and
everything but please I'm talking my
channel 1 video guys Jared - we have a
predominantly male audience so I know
they all watch The Bachelorette
obviously that's how he was introduced
to the world come to find out he's
actually a huge geek - Knossos movies
really well but on collider been on
screen junkies and now he's here he
really knows how to upgrade his Greg
support that's how you do it man that's
how you do it and we were talking about
ready player one a little bit you know
what I'm gonna save my talk about ready
player one for the video so there's some
featurette that the Warner Brothers
release called see the future let's
watch this first then we'll talk about
what's going on here right cool
I follow Jared on Twitter keep a little
[Music]
look at all the great films Spielberg's
done come on like this doesn't give you
the feels I could not have written ready
player one if I had not grown up on a
steady diet of Steven Spielberg movies
it would have been a different story or
I might not have written it and all his
work is woven into the fabric over here
for so good everybody I think who dreams
of making movies dreams of getting to
work with him it's between come true
this john believes during the score
party play my bet is he better be he
always does i don't know what he's doing
what kind of movie is this i suddenly
saw a future that earned his client the
writer the book envision it wasn't that
far away from what i think is going to
happen well someday
I live here in Columbus Ohio in 2045
Columbus is the fastest-growing city on
earth but it sure doesn't seem like it
when you live in a stack ah there's a
dystopian society and the fabric of our
economy is crumbling it's a good time to
escape so virtual reality will be a
super drug they called our generation 2
missing millions missing not because we
went anywhere there's nowhere left to go
nowhere except the Oasis
why does it sound a six-shot talk about
a Spielberg shot I was very careful with
early collaborating with me every step
of the way to be able to find the movie
narrative inside this dense forest alone
imagination the Oasis being the ultimate
toy box with all the toys in the world
and then playing that with one of the
greatest filmmakers of all time it
results in just amazing action and such
a fun adventure
[Music]
Wow whoa
[Music]
ernest cline is such a visionary I had
seen the future before any of us
possibly could even imagine it
ah hmm interesting
well Jared how do you feel I'm not as
excited after watching this as I was
after seeing the trailer that is so
weird because that's got me more
intrigued like the exact flip I mean
it's cool like it's cool it's a cool
little feature what do you want from the
movie nostalgia I think I think that's
like one of the biggest ones seeing it
on the big screen
specifically in 3d IMAX will be
breathtaking it's such a
computer-generated world that I think
it's tough to watch on a computer screen
but on big screen I'm asked I think it
will take my breath away it looks like a
movie that's meant to be seen at the
theater totally seeing like King Kong
the DeLorean honestly it's that stuff
that really doesn't get me excited
because think about it all this stuff
they're showing you like Freddy Krueger
the King Kong looks cool in a trailer
but they're probably just in that one
moment in the movie that's character
what I'm hoping is that the majority of
this movie takes place in the Oasis yeah
not in the real world like it was cool
watching him in the real world and
seeing like the woman with the VR
glasses like stripping as if she's maybe
that was like her dream yeah it's kind
of like the matrix I want to be in the
matrix I want an oasis that I always
wanted to be in Sion I never cared about
I was always like get out of the matrix
guys movie I'll always be excited for
his field of movie and then I hope John
Williams composes it cuz even in the
beginning when they were playing like
all the scenes from Jaws and there's a
loss are all those classics et so on and
so forth like what really gets me is the
music I'm hoping that John Williams
comes back and scores this and has a
really good on track I feel like all
that could be effective what gets me
concerned is is this movie gonna be
balanced well what I hear is all this
talk about you know how he sees the
future and how virtual reality is
becoming this overconsumption that's
gonna continue no really consumer lives
then I see the trailer is only well this
kind of just looks like it's a cool
spectacle film and not so much about the
philosophy and all those things when I
feel like when you have a book like
ready player one what makes the book
is not spectacle because you're just
reading and who makes it cool is the
character and the story and the themes
all those things where I feel like in a
film you might not have as much time to
really dive into all that to really
explore all that there's very few films
like a matrix which can have philosophy
and all these conversations and then
balance it with cool action and
breathtaking visuals and it's been a
while since Phil Brooks done crazy
spectacle film my concern is that it
might lose sight of what the story is
truly about he's saying in these
featurettes and I don't really get
fooled by featurettes anymore to be
honest because they always say the right
thing one part of me is like oh it's
cool here the smoker really closely with
him when developing this movie but you
hear that in every there's always the
safe things to say in a feature read and
I feel like there's the other flip side
of the audience which is more of what
like you were talking about you yeah I
really want the nostalgia honed in on I
want both like you said I do want
balance I want tones of fear of the
future and where we're going as a
society of course and the idea with
these characters and their use of
virtual reality and how they lose
themselves and I want both I want that
because it's true to the book but I also
want the spectacle when I first saw this
trailer and you see all the nostalgia
that's put into this movie I couldn't
help but get butterflies from it cuz
like I'm a huge film gush huge geek and
so the idea of seeing these things I
know that it's only gonna be you know
the DeLoreans not gonna be in the entire
movie or like they're gonna use Freddy
Krueger in one scene but it would be
[ __ ] awesome if it's just like this
badass scene and I do have faith in
Spielberg to be able to balance it
because while he hasn't done big
spectacle he has done good movies I
haven't seen a post yet but I really
enjoyed British PI's makes good movies
and like it's cool to see him back kind
of like doing the big blockbuster thing
again yeah like it was his last
blockbuster other than Tintin it was a
small film called Indiana Jones and the
Kingdom of the Crystal Skull
I mean don't get me wrong the visuals
look cool I bet no matter what there's
gonna be something to take away from
this film that is really cool
it's a Spielberg movie like no matter
what happens even yeah not good we're
gonna have something that was cool the
show's haven't really been giving me as
a character I'm really hooked on I don't
even know the kid is poor what's the
real plot of this movie
I agree like it's like you said the
marketing campaign is solely predicated
on the nostalgia fact yeah and like this
is the first time I've seen any type of
story the story about the themes and the
philosophies everything who wants to
explore it well if the movie does that I
would find this way more intrigue and
then we get a real sci-fi film and I
think over the sci-fi is great I think
so too
it could be a good film I mean every
most people are excited I'm one of the
few who's going out there being like I'm
a little skeptical and yeah I think
virtual reality is taking over the
future the other day I was making alone
with my girlfriend and then she put on a
VR mask and it was his footage of you
the whole time flowing out it's like
that black mirror yeah yeah I did VR is
taking over the world there's like VR
took over the porn industry now I would
know there's like bodysuit apparently
it's like started in Japan there's like
a bodysuit that you put on dude VR
glasses and so you're in you're like
having sex with this VR girl but it has
like sensors so it's like if she touches
you on your arm like it will pressurize
there to me why do you like it there's
obviously something for you dick it's
[ __ ] crazy no I will never have to
sleep with my girlfriend ever again
isn't it like what do you think about it
yeah it's just like yeah I want the
movie to deal with how we're gonna get
so consumed with VR and get so attached
to reality he was jacking off in the
beginning of it
it's the home video I made show us the
recorder
ready player one you guys can subscribe
to the real rejects click that
notification bell to get notified every
time a video of ours is up Jarrod
highborn follow him at Twitter what's
your Twitter haven underscore Jarrod
Haven Haven hate hey Ben hey Ben I'm at
her last name yeah haven't sinned hey
highborn yeah I even say whatever I
don't care
[Laughter]
it's h AI boa
there's no R know that I bet I need a
change it was you my contractors like
noise points Dylan like his Jack Sparrow